Jody Holman is a biologist this is
sometimes how we have to have to feed
them right now though she's also
mosquito food yeah it's a sacrifice but
it's all being made in the name of
science
Holman works with the consolidated
mosquito abatement district in Fresno
County California where they're trying a
new strategy to kill off an invasive
species called 80s Egypt I these
mosquitoes are creeping further north
and with temperatures rising they're
finding more and more places to call
home and that's concerning because these
are the ones that can transmit viruses
like dengue yellow fever and a new
threat in the United States
Zika it's our job to try to do
everything we can to minimize the risk
of disease transmission and also to
minimize the potential for mosquito
bites and they're doing it by breeding
and releasing more mosquitoes every week
we're releasing 40,000 male mosquitoes
it may seem like they're making matters
worse but these mosquitoes are a kind of
biological Trojan horse it begins back
at a lab where mosquito eggs are
injected with a bacteria called
Wolbachia once they're all grown up
the team releases adult males with the
bacteria into ATS a gypsy hot spots like
this neighborhood in Clovis California
when a male that's carrying this
bacteria mates with a female that is not
carrying the bacteria those eggs that
she develops will not hatch and so they
will not develop into larvae unless
adult I don't know what's in that little
tube that you just let out clearly not
everybody likes the new program
somebody's in a lab somebody's working
somebody's making insects and releasing
them 40 feet from my border of my house
and nobody bats an eye this is the
science that supports what we're doing
this is the research we have residents
that choose to not believe that there's
nothing that we can do about that okay
they may be annoying but the mosquitoes
they're releasing don't actually pose
any threats only the females bite they
need the blood to produce eggs so male
mosquitoes don't bite which is one of
the reasons why we agreed to be a part
of this particular program
- really curb the spread of diseases
like Zika everyone will have to chip in
residents need to realize that they can
do much more to protect themselves by
eliminating all sources dumping all
standing water when you're dealing with
living organisms I don't think there is
such a thing as a silver bullet in the
meantime
scientists like Holman will keep doing
what they're doing despite the hazards
of the job let it when they flat my nose